hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein zuschauer rezept und
zwar ist es eigentlich auch ein bisschen
international und zwar gibt es diese
leckeren kokos würfel die kokons würfel
gibt sowohl in australien da heißen sie
lenken als auch in kroatien reisen will
mein gott das ist folter zungenbrecher
für mich auf jeden fall gibt es die in
den zwei ländern
und das ist so ein lockerer teig mit
einer schokoladenglasur außen rum und
kokosraspeln es ist wirklich sehr
schnell hergestellt also ich hab ja ich
brauche so ungefähr mit backen eine
stunde und da müssen sie noch mal kurz
kühlen und dann sind sie wirklich schon
verzehr bereit
also ich finde das sind so ganz lockere
würfel mit dieser klasse außenrum sehr
schokoladig und sehr saftig und am
besten zeige ich euch jetzt erstmal die
zutaten für den teig und später dann die
restlichen zutaten und wir starten
direkt für den teig brauche ich vier
eier 200 gramm zucker eine prise salz
etwas vanille extrakt 100 gramm öl 125
milliliter milch 250 gramm mehl und ein
päckchen backpulver die zutaten sind
alle zimmer waren bis auf die milch die
hatte ich eben aus dem kühlschrank
geholt
deswegen fühle ich die milch jetzt in
einen kleinen topf und lasst ihr einfach
lauwarm werden also gerade so ein
bisschen mache ich jetzt nebenher und
kann in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
eier in die küchenmaschine geben
ihr könnt es natürlich auch im
handrücken rühren
dann kommt der zucker mit dazu das salz
und etwas vanille extrakt und jetzt
lasse ich die eier zucker mischungen
richtig cremig rühren das dauerte etwa
vier bis fünf
jetzt ist die mädels lauwarm
jetzt kann ich die auch mit dazu geben
und auch das öl und rührt es jetzt ganz
kurz bei niedriger stufe durch
und jetzt werden mehl und backpulver
gemischt und auch dazu gegeben
die gebe ich jetzt durch ein sieb und
erzähle ich alles mit einem teig sarah
und
den teig fühle ich jetzt in den
vorbereiteten back rahmen und zwar habe
ich da an eckigen genommen und habe den
auch 24 x 24 cm eingestellt
unser wird der teig im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 170 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 30 minuten gebacken ich mache
dann die stäbchen probe und lasst den
kuchen komplett abkühlen
der kuchenteig ist abgekühlt und ich
habe ihn auch auf zimmertemperatur
kommen lassen und ihn dann für etwa eine
halbe stunde im kühlschrank gestellt
dann kann ich ihn nämlich gleich auch
besser zurecht schneiden und während ich
jetzt gleich schneider mache ich schon
mal den guss denn die sehr kuchenstücke
werden dann gleich in schokoladenglasur
getaucht und für den guss brauch ich
folgende zutaten
ich habe 500 gramm puderzucker 250 gramm
mädels 40 gramm kakaopulver 15 gramm
butter und 200 gramm koks raste und
jetzt stelle ich erstmal diesen bus her
nun gibt dafür jetzt puderzucker in
einen kleinen topf
und da gibt's übrigens ist auch
verschiedene möglichkeiten um das zu
machen also im kroatischen kündigte so
dass man es auch mit bitterschokolade
macht und mit sahne oder mit milch im
australischen macht man eher mit kakao
und mit zucker also stellt dann selber
diese schokolade her
deswegen mache ich jetzt einfach auch
mit cacau so puderzucker milch und
kakaopulver aus jetzt da rein und gibt
auch noch die butter mit dazu und jetzt
stelle ich den herd an und lass die
mischung auf kochen natürlich erstmal
gut durchrühren damit die ganzen
klümpchen auch weg gehen und sich alles
gut verbindet
ich habe ein großes rad der minuten
kochen lassen hab ihn letztens also den
herrn ausgestellt und kann sich ein
bisschen abkühlen lassen und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal den
kuchen zurechtschneiden und zwar ist er
bei mir etwa 4 cm hoch das heißt ich
schneid den jetzt auch im 4 cm stücke
dann habe ich nämlich quadrate dazu
nimmt ihr am besten ein lineal dann hab
das einfach ganz genau
jetzt habe ich das alles zurecht
geschnitten und jetzt habe ich hier drei
täler und zwar im einen ist es der
schokokuss drin im einem die
kokosraspeln und einer ist leer
ich hab mit kokosraspeln und nicht alle
rein gegeben und auch vom bus noch nicht
komplett alles damit einfach nicht so
heiß ist also dass er immer wieder
abkühlen kann
und jetzt nehme ich mir so ein stück
kuchen und tunkt es jetzt von allen
seiten da rein
deswegen habe ich jetzt auch handschuhe
an weil jetzt nicht möchte dass meine
ganze hand gleich vor der schublade ist
einfach nur ganz kurz und dann in die
kokons raste mit vollständig damit
ummanteln
am besten geht es auch zu zweit dann
kann eine den kuchen in diese mischung
tauchen und einer dann in kokons helfen
auf dem rad
und so mache ich jetzt weiter bis alle
aufgebraucht sind
die super g oder die elemente die sind
jetzt fertig ihr müsst beim arbeiten
darauf achten dass ihr sie auf eine
fläche mit kokos draufsetzt weil die
tropfen dann noch mal eine zeit lang
dann können die sich da noch mal einfach
mit kokos vollsaugen und am besten
verzeihen ist einfach gut durch gekühlt
und murat darf jetzt einfach mal
probieren mit der hand ein gehalt am
besten über einem teller weil sonst
bröselt muss ein bisschen und dies ist
jetzt ein ganz weiter teig und hat mal
außenrum diese schoko schicht und dann
diese kokosflocken ich rede ich finde
die auch richtig gut
und die sind als sehr einfach zu machen
der teig ist zu verlockend
und ja die restlichen zutaten hatten
eigentlich auch immer daran ich hab das
schokoladige gerne schokolade sich und
ihr dürft rechtlich erschrecken vor der
zuckermenge in dieser klasse die muss so
sein weil ansonsten wird diese klasse
einfach nicht dickflüssig dann ist es
alles viel zu dünn und durch den zucker
wird es ebenso ein bisschen angelegt wie
sonst sehr gut besonders typisches aus
und sieht aus dem lokal ihres
wohlstandes zubereitet hat will ja auf
alle aufpassen musste ja aber ich habe
beispielsweise locken mäßig glaub schon
kuchen und ich habe auch schon gesehen
dass es das auch in polen zum beispiel
gibt also ich denke es gibt einfach in
verschiedenen ländern uns heißt einfach
mal anders
ihr könnt mir mal gerne schreiben ob ihr
wisst wo es diese spezialität noch
geriet sie ist in diesem land in
australien heißen sie lenken und in
kroatien heißen super ski pool gibt es
auch ich kriege und in polen gibt es
auch ja das haben die bestimmt von
australien geklaut mitmachen wollt geht
auf meinem blog aufs tennis - block
sailer stets noch mal ganz genau und ich
bin die wirklich super lecker saftig und
sehr schokoladig also viel spaß beim
nachhaken und bis zum nächsten mal
jetzt passe ich auf männer auf und du
kampf nur politiker freuen gleich
wirklich klasse
selbstverständlich